Good question.
Ask yourself what would motivate you?
You know,
first of all,
don't be studying eight hours a day cause that isn't going to work and you're
not going to do it anyways.
You know,
when you start studying five minutes a day,
seriously,
would you,
could you bring it up to 10 minutes a day?
What would you have to do for yourself to get yourself to sit down for half an
hour a day and,
and study intently?
Like maybe you'd have to,
I don't know what you'd have to do,
like have a beer at six o'clock at night or something.
Or maybe you'd have to go for a walk in the park or go out for coffee.
It's like,
imagine that you're sitting down with a stupid undisciplined child who,
and you're trying to get that child to do something useful and you say,
okay,
look,
I want you to do x.
It's necessary,
but you can pick how much of it you're going to do and I'll give you what you
want if you do it well,
ask yourself that and see what happens.
So don't try to tyrannized yourself,
you know,
try to negotiate with yourself and use some reward and see how that works and
start slow.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not very disciplined and the best you can do is half an hour of
studying a day.
Well start with half an hour.
Increase that five minutes a week.
You know,
if you do that,
that's a lot.
If you,
if you do that for a year,
then you'll,
by the end of the year,
you'll be studying four hours a day.
So you can eat.
That's,
that's just with five,
that's just with five minutes a week,
right?
Because that's 250 minutes in a year.
So start ridiculously pathetically study for five minutes a day for a week and
then move it to 10 you may have to do that and don't cheat.
You know,
because one of the things people do is they make a deal with themselves like
that.
I'm all,
I'm going to study for 10 minutes a day each day.
And then they,
they get into it,
they think,
wow,
this is going really good.
So they study for two hours and then they broken the contract with themselves
and they don't trust themselves anymore.
And then they don't study for a whole year or,
well,
maybe not for a month.
So,
but set your contract,
ask yourself,
you know,
what could I do to move myself forward to my goal that I would do?
And then how can I improve that incrementally?
So that's the right way of going about that.
So,
okay.